just a heads up everybody the audio on
this might sound a little distorted
because I was actually screaming so much
I blew out the mic
I'm sure you'll take that as a good sign
enjoy
okay so I've seen a lot of Disney
sequels this year and I've hated a lot
of them but for some reason some strange
reason Mulan - I hate the most
now that's not saying it's the worst
it's not the words animated it's not the
worst story the third Beauty and the
Beast probably has that distinction but
something about this one just rubbed me
so the wrong way and got me legitimately
angry which is so strange because the
first one I didn't even get that into I
mean I liked it if I was fine and some
good moments and stuff but something
about this one just made me appreciate
it all the more when I see what it could
have been how awful it could have turned
out Mulan is back home training a bunch
of kids how to be little warrior
princesses winner boyfriend drops by and
proposes she of course says yes but this
looks like bad news for Mu Shu not voice
thank God by Eddie Murphy this time but
a much more unfunny Eddie Murphy
impersonator who's going to lose his job
because he no longer has to look after
Mulan so it's up to him to try and
what's a couple of parts yeah doesn't
that make him incredibly likable but
come on this is the sequel to Mulan this
girl that went and defeated this army
surely some actions got to be in here
well the Emperor of China sees that the
Huns are about to attack okay here we go
now we're going to get some good sword
fighting he calls a Mulan and was he
ever do it squirt these three princesses
to be married yeah because a marriage
will unite these two kingdoms and thus
they can fight the Huns together well
wait that's it that's really it
I mean don't get me wrong the movie
makes it very clear early on that isn't
just about fighting and violence it's
about the center and peace and
tranquility of the mind but is it really
this is the plot of course they bring in
the comic relief from the last film and
they're gonna fall in love with them
there's going to be this whole thing
about oh sure they marry or should they
not you know choose your heart all that
bla bla bla but here's the thing it
isn't like being forced to marry just
cuz you're forced to marry because a
tradition the future of China relies on
this that throws in a completely
different element but Mulan doesn't care
your girlfriend's be happy but to make
things worse Mushu is constantly trying
to split up the main couple throughout
the entire movie and I mean the entire
movie he suddenly becomes the most
despicable unlikable character in the
world and what makes it even worse is
that it kind of works the boyfriend just
goes off on the lawn in this really
uncomfortable animation my god what the
hell is he even doing Mulan at some
point through some realizes
that wasn't true and she's going to fall
in love with him again and marry him but
then he disappears so she thinks now she
has to marry one of these princes to
unite the two kingdoms the climax every
dumb ass romantic comedy you've ever
seen where the bride is going to marry
the person she doesn't want to marry and
the guy has to come in confess his love
and some sort of dumb comedic ass
happens I'm just going to warn you I'm
going to get into spoiler territory here
but I'm sorry this is really important
to talk about so Mushu tries to make
everything better by telling them that
they don't have to marry well okay the
three princesses marry the man they
wanna marries the boyfriend but what
about China they're doomed
there's no Alliance the Huns are going
to attack China is officially destroyed
because of this but at least they're
marrying for true love
it's never addressed what happens after
this I wouldn't make that make a deal
out of it I know directed Disney sequel
haha but they make a big deal out of it
think you're talking over and over why
they can't get married how thousands
will die if they don't join this union
and in the end I guess they just let
thousands die it's it's really awful
there's only one good song in the whole
thing and it's the first song all the
others are either hand-me-downs or
repeats yeah they just repeat half the
songs girl worth fighting for comes back
that'll say from having to write another
paycheck the animation while smooth and
colorful also kind of looks out of place
the London the original had a pretty
good range of emotion but here all the
animation is kind of done like they're
comic relief they're too expressive
they're too rubbery which like I said
makes for some really awkward scenes
when the boyfriend has to yell at her
bill oh that's disturbing
don't know what it is because like I
said I didn't get super into the first
film but something about this was just
so insulting and so demeaning the
choices were just so bad and maybe the
fact that they did put in this really
good animation just made the insult
greater if it had the animation of say
Tarzan and Jane or one of these TV
pilots I forgive it a little bit more
but you know that they put in a lot of
effort like yes this is the script this
is going to be Mulan too
this is going to be what everyone is
going to get behind I don't know it just
really frigging earth to me and all the
characters are unlikable and generic and
bland and not interesting or stupid or
just mean-spirited I can't believe what
an asshole Mushu is as a boyfriend
everyone for letting the entire
everything of China die because follow
your heart which is like oh my god what
is wrong with this movie it is a mess it
is awful it just got under my skin I
hated it so much like I said I can't say
it's officially the worst there's
definitely been worth Disney sequels but
this one so far I've hated the most it
sucks it really sucks if I ever had a
kid and they wanted to see this I say no
I just show him a person Mulan again oh
I don't even know what to say about it
just skip it don't check it out if you
really love the movie Mulan or even just
think it's okay like I do avoid this at
all cost the only thing it is and made
me appreciate the first one a lot more
so I guess I'll give it that
but for everything else this movie can
friggin blow me
[Music]
you